I have never been more sure before
uploading a video that I was going to
upset some people than I am on this one
which is kind of ironic because that's
sort of what I'm talking about but this
is a thing I've been meaning to say for
a while that just keeps becoming
relevant and I feel like every time it
does it melts my brain and it is not
video game related sometimes I think
about things other than video games I
know I'm as shocked as you are and I
don't know if maybe I'm very stupid it's
entirely possible people have said as
such for a long time but I've never seen
anybody else share this sentiment um
yeah which either means that I'm really
dumb or people have been saying it for a
long time and I just haven't seen it
which is equally as likely both of those
good possibilities could go either way
so you may have heard of comedian Matt
re who kind of blew up on Tik Tok and
has now had his own standup comedy
special on Netflix which has been
controversial and I believe he kind of
rose to TiK ToK startom by being
handsome and flirting with audiences
which there's a market for it I actually
think think we underestimate just how
much being handsome and flirting with
young women like has made some careers I
just feel like young women like really
economically push people to start them
his standup special that is U making
news headlines includes a very early
domestic abuse joke right in the
beginning of the standup and has
generated a whole bunch of headlines
this week including is Matt re the
manosphere next it boy Jordan Peterson
consoles comedian who mocked beaten
women stole jokes and is beefing online
with a plastic
surgeon what a headline Matt R is such a
great comic that he needs Jordan
Peterson to explain why he's funny as an
aside I don't know who Jordan Peterson
is I think I get him confused with the
one who told his wife to watch it you
know the guy who was like watch it watch
it I think they're the same dude and
they're not the same dude Jordan
Peterson is a psychologist they podcast
guy I don't know whatever and then the
Vox headline here is Matt R's
controversial Netflix special natural
selection every time this happens and it
does happen repeatedly I feel like my
brain is melting and there are several
layers of this that like actively keep
me up at night I'm recording this at
like 3:00 a.m. I mean if I'm being
honest it's the jet lag that's keeping
me up but I am still talking to you
about this now we have this culture of a
stand-up comedian saying some joke
that's pretty easy is punch Downy and
getting so much attention for it in a
way that it's just weird to me that
nobody sees how convenient that is Matt
r makes a domestic abuse joke some
people are offended by the joke and then
another group of people is extremely
offended that other people are offended
by the joke and what happens as a result
is Matt RVE standup is exponentially
more popular this suggestion that
stand-up comedians are being cancelled
and the audiences are too sensitive
which W do I have a lot to say about
audiences being too sensitive which we
will get to because they are not in the
way that you think but there's this like
reaction to like okay this person
doesn't like a joke then this entire
other audience comes in and is like
they're allowed to make jokes they can
make jokes about whatever they want and
then you look at Netflix standup
specials and the way that they're titled
and it all says edgy not politically
correct offensive it is a marketing
tactic we are helping these people
Market every time that you read some
sensitive comment that you disagree with
and you yell you you're sensitive it
just circulates more and more news
clearly is playing into the hands of
Netflix this is clearly a marketing
strategy that they are using over and
over and over again and people are
falling for
over and over and over again I would not
be surprised if Netflix actively
encourages their standup comedians to
say something offensive to make a very
lame easy quick offensive joke within
their special for marketing purposes the
minute that it Sparks controversy is the
same minute that that stand-up special
explodes and that person's name is all
over the news and it just keeps
happening over and over and over and
over and over again and there are like
two points to oh [__] Matt R for that
jerk he made which to be clear I haven't
even heard I haven't watched the special
not because of the joke that he made
just I've been doing other [__] I don't
know but everybody who hears about that
news gets so curious CU they're like is
it offensive am I going to be offended I
think I'm stronger than that you can't
offend me and it becomes a challenge you
become compelled to watch this Netflix
special so that you can go on social
media about how it wasn't offensive and
no matter what happens for all of this
conversation none of these comedians
ever actually gets hard done by it
anyway there's this like weird culture
War to defend these people who nothing
is happening to them none of these
people are actually being canceled the
conversation that we keep having about
these standup comedians and how they
can't make jokes anymore I know people
are too sensitive and get a sense of
humor they're just sitting back and like
rolling in money just drowning in
Netflix cash and we're all just having
the same conversations over and over and
over again every single time like it's
not playing exactly into their hands can
we can we just stop can we just stop
doing this and it's a crazy part of
having a job I make YouTube videos where
I give my opinions on things people
frequently don't like those opinions
like all the time like it every day
people give me say they don't like what
I said right at no point am I ever like
I'm a YouTuber it's my job to give my
opinion how dare you because people gave
me feedback this I don't know why we
treat comedians like it's different
they're allowed to make a joke and
someone is allowed to not like that joke
and someone is allowed to tell them that
they didn't like that joke they're not
immune from criticism because they're
saying [__] on a stage like it doesn't
make any sense that we get so protective
of comedians specifically nothing is
happening to them they all just fine and
very rich probably don't care if you
defend them or not which is feeding into
the marketing cycle I'm sure most of you
already know about this but this is an
article on crack.com written by JD
Robinson um that lists 15 times
comedians were actually arrested for
comedy this is a thing that was
happening somewhat regularly in the same
era that I think a lot of people were
like comedy Used to Be Alive used to be
able to say whatever you want people
were literally jailed for the kind of
jokes that they made the equivalent now
is just just a couple of people got mad
on social media that's so much better
that is such a big Improvement Lenny
Bruce extremely famously known as a
Trailblazer for free speech and comedy
was arrested several times over the
years for obscene language who's
arrested most famously this is the story
that I'm sure most of you have heard of
in 1961 and arrested again in Chicago
the next year for the same reason and
was deported from the UK the next year
and arrested twice in New York a year
after that effectively before Lenny
Bruce like actively very strongly
intervened there wasn't even that much
first amendment protection in comedy it
has gotten better not worse you used to
not be allowed to say whatever you
wanted you could literally get arrested
for saying [__] he had an
obscenity trial that's how bad this used
to be it has only gotten so much more
chill now here's to the second part of
this video which I feel very strongly
about and I hope people are still here
probably a lot of people are already
gone it is what it is there is this
sentiment that human beings are too damn
sensitive you can't make a joke about
anything these days and that is true
however humans have literally always
been sensitive there has been no
increase there is an increase of sorts
but it is not sensitivity there there
are layers there are a couple examples
that I love to pull up about this
particular sentiment here's this like
lovely little um news clipping called
nobody wants to work anymore 1979 nobody
wants to work anymore newspaper headline
1981 they didn't want to work nobody
wants to work anymore 1999 nobody wants
to work anymore 2006 nobody wants to
work anymore 2014 what has happened to
the work ethic in America nobody wants
to work anymore it has not always been
that way when I first started to work as
a teenager I saw people work hard 2022
no one wants to work anymore the same
thing applies to men aren't real men
anymore the first men aren't real men
article I could find was in 1920 men
aren't real men that conversation has
been happening for so long what's
happening to masculinity in America
here's an article from
1958 this is a pause because I
originally ACD accidentally said 1985
called the crisis of American
masculinity something has gone badly
wrong with American men but a solution
exists for recovering masculinity what
happened to the American male for a long
time he seemed utterly confident in his
manhood sure of his masculine role in
society easy and definite in his sense
of sexual
identity I think I'm really bad at that
it goes on to actively criticize authors
specifically outlines Hemingway here I
mean this is the same thing that we
would do with certain social media you
know you'll see people on Fox News
saying what's happening to America
masculinity back in my day we were men
and then this person showed up this is
literally sighting Hamming way these
same conversations repeat themselves all
the time people have been outraged about
the same [__] for forever and here's my
my thesis here and it definitely feeds
into standup comedy human beings have
always been sensitive people used to get
stoned in the streets for adultery if a
woman cheated on a man they would
literally murder her that's pretty
[__] sensitive people used to have
their hands cut off for stealing bread
that's pretty [__] sensitive you used
to get murdered for being gay that's
pretty fu [__] sensitive you were
that upset or offended that a man kissed
another man that you murdered him and
everybody just agreed that that was okay
that's pretty [__] sensitive that's
not to mention the amount of times that
older Generations who claim kids these
days are too sensitive have tried to
Outlaw video games I've tried to Outlaw
bans they tried to ban The Beatles for
saying that they were as big as Jesus in
the 60s that was truly the most
outrageous thing that anybody had ever
said was that the Beatles were bigger
than Jesus which at the time they may
have been very sensitive people tried to
ban metal music saying that it was
related to the devil people have tried
to ban certain books you used to be
imprisoned for swearing on the street
swearing humans are really [__]
sensitive in general and have always
been sensitive we aren't becoming more
sensitive it's the same level of
sensitivity it's just about different
[__] and you know as a sidebar I think
that happens because humans have all of
their needs met right you've got like
the hierarchy of needs you start
becoming sensitive when you've got
shelter food clothing water and
community and I really feel like it's
it's like the curse of mankind like
humans knowing that they're going to die
been reading a lot of non-fiction lately
okay and it's done some things to my
brain but like you have all your needs
met and then you're like what the [__]
is the purpose what am I here for and so
we just get so caught up in identity and
how much identity matters and I am this
person and this is what I stand for I
must say this because Legacy and so you
get these sensitivities that rise to the
top because people are just trying to
find a meaning to why they exist all I'm
saying is if we didn't know that we were
mortal I think things would play out
very differently that is heightened of
course by social media which I just
think we all take too seriously people
especially on websites like Twitter and
I think it's happening more in like
Instagram comments or Tik Tok are
incentivized to give the most heightened
version of an opinion not only because
word limits ruin Nuance you have to say
a very direct statement but also because
the most outrageous thing possible is
the one that gets the most engagement so
if you give the strongest version of an
opinion that you may not have in real
life you are going to be rewarded for
that on social media in a negative or
positive way it doesn't really matter
you just just going to see more
engagement so no I don't think we're
more sensitive but yes I do think we're
more inflammatory it's also just that
you have access to more voices you can
see more people's opinions now than you
ever could before did you know that
crime rates have gone down since the 80s
I asked an older gentleman recently what
it was like to grow up in the ' 80s like
to be you know in his 20s and the 80s
and he said it was so free we weren't
worried about anything we just did what
we wanted crime now is so bad you know
crime rates have been decreasing since
the ' 80s especially since the '90s it's
like rapid decrease and yet if you paid
attention into social media or news you
would think that it is tremendously
increased this is a perception that I
think access has given us you have more
access to hear about horrific crime and
thus you think crime rates are higher
they're not you are actually way less
safe in the 80s than you are now and
this whole thing is really just part of
One Singular machine the whole thing is
marketing all just feeding into one
funnel that is Netflix standup comedy
special my thesis is this this is a trap
that everybody just keeps falling for
the problem with me saying that is that
I think we've fallen for this same trap
100 years over and I don't think it's
going anywhere